(ominous guitar music)
- [Nahre] Goth is an entire
subculture which inspired
not only decades of music,
but fashion and films.
(ominous guitar music)
- In fact, the unique look
associated with goth culture
is as much a part of the
brand as is melancholy music.
Where country has its
belt buckles and boots,
goth has its tripp pants and chains,
but we wanna know what came first.
Was it the moody fashion
or was it the music?
(upbeat techno music)
- So we're not talking about
the Hot Topic mall goths.
This was something that came straight out
of the late '70s post-punk scene.
It was the dark, moody black
lipstick wearing specter
known as goth rock.
- Goth's influence can be seen everywhere,
from Tim Burton movies to Billie Eilish.
There's even an annual goth cruise.
(foghorn blowing)
(seagulls cawing)
- Today, LA and I are going
to embrace our inner goths,
put on the black mascara and lipstick,
and create an appropriately moody song,
but first we're going to talk about
where this sub-culture really started.
So, aside from the silver
jewelry and black jeans,
what exactly is goth?
Firstly, we need to get into the vibe
by reading Edgar Allan Poe.
Sorry.
Let's look it up now.
"No doubt I now grew very pale,
"but I talked more fluently
and with a heightened voice."
- "Villians, I shrieked.
"Dissemble no more, I admit the deed.
"Tear the planks here,
"here is the beating
of this hideous heart."
Oh my goodness.
- That's dark.
- [LA] While the term
Gothic originally came about
to describe European
architecture of the Middle Ages,
from roughly the 12th
Century through the 16th,
the term was later used to describe
romantic and spooky literature
from the 1700s and 1800s.
- So what does that have to do
with the moody musical style?
Most give credit to music
critic John Stickney
for connecting the term with the music.
After meeting Jim Morrison of The Doors
in a gloomy wine cellar in 1967,
he wrote that it was the perfect room
to honor the gothic rock of The Doors,
referencing the somber lyrics
and dark musical stylings of the band.
♪ This is the end ♪
But by the late '70s and early '80s,
goth rock was a genre.
- Where did goth rock come from?
It's considered to be an offshoot
of the late '70s British punk
rock scene called post-punk.
Post-punk took the energy
and the do-it-yourself spirit
of punk in bold,
experimental new directions,
blending punk with
influences from other genres
like disco, funk, and electronic music.
While punk was considered
an angry rebel yell
at the establishment,
goth became the opposite,
a fatalistic, romantic
resignation to the inevitable.
(clock bell ringing)
- During this time, three bands
really came to the forefront
of the emerging genre
to become the pioneers
of the goth rock movement,
Joy Division, Siouxsie and
the Banshees, and Bauhaus.
So what made these goth bands so gothic?
- Goth music is often
identified by its dark themes
and is considered nihilistic and poetic.
A recurring heavy bass,
a moody synthesizer,
and the use of echo doesn't hurt either.
Perhaps what can be
considered as the archetype
for all goth music was Bauhaus'
single, Bela Lugosi's Dead,
which came out, and in
1979 as considered by many
to be the first truly gothic rock song.
♪ Bela Lugosi's dead ♪
♪ The bats have left the bell tower ♪
Bela Lugosi was an actor who
played the title character
in Universal's 1931 film,
Dracula, and whose real life
was almost as tragic as his fictional one.
The band's bassist,
David J, said he came up
with the idea for the song and wrote it
after binge watching vampire
movies on television.
The band's front man, Peter Murphy,
said the sound of the song was in part
also inspired by dub reggae.
You can hear the influence.
Listen to The Revolutionaries'
Reaction in Dub from 1978,
(dub reggae music)
and here's Bela Lugosi's Dead.
(punk reggae music)
Bauhaus' song may be
considered goth's first anthem,
but it was just the beginning
for the musical genre.
The English band Siouxsie and
the Banshees formed in 1976,
taking their name from the
horror movie Cry of the Banshee,
which starred another classic
of horror, Vincent Price.
Some argue Siouxsie and
the Banshees was originally
a punk band that transitioned
to post-punk goth
with their fourth album, Juju, in 1981.
♪ We are entranced, we are entranced ♪
♪ Spellbound ♪
But there's no debate that
lead singer Siouxsie Sioux
heavily influenced goth fashion,
but more on that later.
- Other bands such as Joy
Division, the Sisters of Mercy,
The Cure, The Damned, Dead
Can Dance, Type O Negative,
and many more put on their capes
and came out of the shadows
with their dark messages of
loneliness and rebellion.
So what exactly are we
getting ourselves into?
(giggling)
- Listen, when I thought
about goth, initially,
I thought it was gonna be super
similar to the metal thing.
I'm like, okay, it's
gonna be a lot of work.
Okay, gotta dig in, but
then hearing actually
goth rock music, it puts me in an era.
Early '80s, it sounds exactly like that,
where the synths were long-y.
- I don't know if this
is a thing throughout,
but a lot of open intervals.
Even if we're not dealing
with unstable harmony,
like an augmented chord,
(plays piano notes)
but still just,
something about this open sound,
it feels like it doesn't really need to
resolve anywhere or go anywhere,
but it also doesn't
feel like it's settled.
(playing piano)
- If you had to resolve that,
if you had to resolve
that, where would you go?
(playing piano notes)
(laughing)
- You don't need to go anywhere.
- Okay, so we know
where the music started.
Can we assume that the fashion and style
began about the same time?
- It may have begun much earlier.
Goth was directly inspired
by the romanticism
of both the Romantic and Victorian era,
drawing some of its earliest inspirations
from Mary Shelley's Frankenstein,
the writings of Edgar
Allan Poe and Bram Stoker,
but oddly enough, the
beginnings of the goth style
may have actually had its roots
in the Victorian tuberculosis epidemic.
The gaunt and pale look of those affected
by the fatal disease
was often romanticized,
influencing the mid-1800s
perceptions of beauty,
which were later adopted by
the emerging goth culture.
- Horror cinema also
inspired gothic style.
Silent film star Theda Bara
was nicknamed the Vamp,
and French actress Sarah
Bernhardt was known
for sleeping in a coffin.
Later, there was pinup model Bettie Page,
Vampira actress Maila Nurmi,
and of course, TV's Elvira.
- [Nahre] Goth was further
cemented in popular culture
in 1976 with Anne Rice's
Interview With the Vampire,
a novel believed to have also
heavily influenced the genre.
- But now, back to Siouxsie
Sioux, the godmother of goth.
Her raven hair and signature
eye makeup was more influenced
by ancient Egyptians than the Victorians,
but once the style was out the gate,
it took on an afterlife of its own.
- The goth culture as we know it today
further developed in 1982 with the opening
of the London goth club, The Batcave.
The club inspired the spooky scene
with regular performances from Bauhaus,
Siouxsie and the Banshees,
as well as many others.
Soon, goth spread across the globe,
infecting many with its
dark music and fashion.
Are you ready to embrace your inner goth?
- Let's get it.
I'm with it.
- Like this?
(snorting)
- I got a bass at the crib,
and so I could definitely lay down.
- Okay.
(clapping)
Yes, I'm all for LA playing bass guitar.
- Tempo-wise, even if we have,
(ticking)
going up top, we could have,
boom, boom, cah.
- Yes!
- It's still driving, it's still marching,
but it's like you're walking,
you're not walking down a sunny street.
You're walkin' in the woods.
- That kinda has to just sound like
we're getting in a dark
crevasse in our head.
- [LA] In the mind, okay.
- I want to add some textures.
There has to be that fuzz.
- They twisted it up, some way some how.
There's a lot of sound
design with those synths.
- Okay, I think we have a plan.
(heavy bass music)
- Wanna know more about
creatures of the night?
Well head over to Monstrum, a PBS show
all about monsters, myths, and folkore
hosted by our friend Dr. Z,
an expert of all things gothic.
(clicking)
(shimmering)